Wow ! (tousse) Y s'passe quoi, Romain, là ? Et, y a le feu à une poubelle ou quoi ?
Bah non, c'est ma cigarette électronique.
Goût saumon.
Vous avez été nombreux à me poser la question dans les commentaires des vidéos précédentes, alors j'ai décidé d'y répondre aujourd'hui.
La cigarette électronique est-elle dangereuse ?
Alors pour commencer, on va se mettre d'accord sur les termes. Une cigarette électronique, ça produit pas de la fumée, mais de la vapeur.
Pour ça, elle fait chauffer grâce à une résistance le liquide qui est contenu dans son réservoir, et qu'on appelle un clearomiseur.
On peut l'utiliser pour plusieurs raisons, comme par exemple comme moyen de substitution au tabac.
Pour arrêter de fumer progressivement, en gardant le geste et la sensation de la fumée qu'on inhale.
C'est pas con, hein ?
J'me demande si y aurait moyen de...
Marre de manger gras ? Passez à la E-raclette DTC et ses liquides fromagers saveur poivre, fumé ou vin blanc.
Vous vous rongez les ongles ? Testez notre ongle électronique.
Vous consommez de l'héroine ? Essayez seringuéo, by DTC.
Et grâce à notre doigt électronique...
Oui, bah ça c'est le truc pour les ongles, tu l'as déjà dit.
Hmmmm non. C'est pas pour ça.
Certains liquides pour cigarette électronique contiennent de la nicotine, et d'autres pas.
Mais c'est pas tellement ça le plus important, car en réalité, la nicotine, c'est ce qui rend accro,
mais c'est pas ce qui rend malade.
Enfin, à haute dose, ça peut être nocif, mais c'est vraiment rien par rapport au reste
La fumée de cigarette, celle avec du tabac,
elle contient plus de 4000 substances chimiques, dont 90 sont toxiques, et une quarantaine cancérogènes.
Ce qui rend malade, ce qui provoque les cancers, c'est ce qu'on appelle les goudrons.
Mais ça, dans la vapeur de cigarette électronique, y en a pas.
Mais, ça ne veut pas dire que ça n'a aucun effet sur la santé.
Le problèmes, c'est qu'il y a DEUX problèmes.
Tout d'abord, la cigarette électronique, elle a pas le même statut que les chewing-gum à la nicotine, les patchs, etc
enfin, tout ce qui est prescrit par un médecin pour arrêter de fumer.
Du coup, les liquides qu'elles contiennent sont pas soumis aux mêmes réglementations, ni aux mêmes surveillances concernant leur composition.
Ce qui nous amène directement au deuxième problème : on a peu d'études fiables sur leur réelle toxicité.
Et surtout, vu que c'est un dispositif relativement récent, on ne sait pas ce que peut donner leur utilisation sur une longue période.
Des chercheurs de l'université de Harvard ont mis en garde contre la présence de diacétyle dans certains liquides de cigarette électronique.
Le diacétyle, c'est un additif alimentaire qui pose pas de problèmes quand on le mange,
mais qui peut entraîner une maladie respiratoire rare, qu'on appelle la bronchiolite oblitérante, quand on le respire.
C'est un arôme qui est utilisé dans l'agroalimentaire pour donner un goût de beurre, ou de fromage.
(Tousse) Non, roquefort, ça pique trop. Je vais vous prendre beurre demi sel.
On s'est rendu compte que ça rendait malade après une multiplication des cas de cette maladie respiratoire rare chez les fabricants de pop corn,
qui respiraient toute la journée cet arôme de beurre.
Dans le cas des cigarettes électroniques, le diacétyle est utilisé notamment pour la fabrication des liquides saveur bonbon ou  saveur gâteau.
Les normes françaises recommandent de ne pas les utiliser, donc normalement, y en a pas dans les liquides made in France.
Normalement, hein.
Parce que les normes, les fabricants sont pas obligés de les suivre.
Toujours en 2015, le New England Journal of Medicine
a publié une étude qui affirmait que la cigarette électronique était 5 à 15 fois plus cancérogène que le tabac.
En cause, une substance appelée le formaldéhyde qui serait libérée quand on surchauffe le liquide.
Mais cette étude a été très controversée.
Les experts ont estimé que pour atteindre de tels chiffres,
il faudrait tellement chauffer le liquide que ça deviendrait impossible de le vapoter.
Attention chez les femmes enceintes aussi, la vapeur contient des substances
qui pourraient présenter un risque pour le développement du foetus
notamment au niveau respiratoire
Là encore on parle d'études menées sur un petit nombre de souris,
c'est pas suffisant pour être sûr, mais c'est suffisant pour être prudent...
et pour continuer les recherches !
Les premières études menées sur les voies respiratoires des vapoteurs
semblent aussi indiquer des conséquences négatives au niveau immunitaire
Prudence aussi chez les asthmatiques.
Bon... de base, fumer quand on est asthmatique, c'est pas une bonne idée.
Bon, ça c'est pour
*bruit synthétique ressemblant à un gaz*
J'essaie d'arrêter, c'est pour ça
Anus électronique DTC, l'essayer, c'est l'adopter!
Bon, ça c'est pour les vapoteurs, mais pour ceux qui sont autour, est-ce que c'est dangereux ?
Une étude norvégienne a montré que le taux de nicotine dans le sang de l'entourage des vapoteurs
était aussi élevé qu'avec des cigarettes classiques
MAIS
comme on l'a vu, la nicotine, c'est pas ça qui est dangereux
Et comme la vapeur des cigarettes électronique ne contient pas de substances vraiment dangereuses
Bon, dans le doute la loi française elle interdit :
La vente aux mineurs et elle interdit aussi de vapoter dans les transports en commun,
sur les lieux de travail fermés, et dans les établissements accueillant des mineurs.
Dans tous les autres lieux publics, comme les bars ou les restos par exemple.
C'est au propriétaire de décider si il interdit, ou pas.
Au delà des risques pour la santé, ce qui inquiète les professionnels,
c'est que les gens recommencent à vapoter là où c'est interdit de fumer.
les interdictions ça commence à peine à rentrer dans les mœurs alors bon...
Ce qui inquiète aussi, c'est que la cigarette électronique se démocratise
et devienne une porte d'entrée dans le tabac au lieu d'être une porte de sortie.
Donc on ne peut pas vraiment dire que la cigarette électronique
est sans danger pour celui qui vapote, ni même pour son entourage.
Par contre ce qu'on peut dire à coup sûr
c'est que les effets négatifs du tabac sur la santé, là il n'y a vraiment pas de doutes
et qu'ils sont assez clairement bien plus méchants que ceux de la cigarette électronique.
Il n'y a pas d'étude scientifique qui démontre de façon certaine
l'efficacité de la cigarette électronique comme moyen d'arrêter de fumer du tabac.
En tous cas rien ne montre que ça marche mieux que les autres méthodes.
Mais on sait que c'est un outil efficace pour réduire sa consommation de tabac
Et rien que ça, c'est déjà pas mal !
Alors si la cigarette électronique c'est un moyen de diminuer sa consommation de tabac
voire de l'arrêter, c'est tout bénéf, il n'y a pas trop besoin de réfléchir !
Par contre si c'est pour continuer de cloper
et se taper un petit shoot de nicotine là où c'est interdit de fumer...
bof.
Bon, vous avez les infos, maintenant vous en faites ce que vous voulez !
Voilà, DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant, mettez-vous bien et surtout, portez-vous bien !
*musique d'outro*